Привет! Это седьмой урок модуля. В уроках предыдущих мы заложили каркас UA-кита, типы компонентов, плотности, функциональные цвета. Но что осталось незакрытым? На базовых компонентах из урока 5 кнопки, input и карточки нет состояния. Нет hover, нет disable, нет loading, нет фокус и так далее. Также там нет размеров. У нас зачастую кнопки как минимум двух размеров есть на сайте. И, как ты мог заметить, наверняка сейчас всего этого нет.
Поэтому в этом уроке эту оплошность мы будем исправлять. В дальнейшем по этим вариациям и этим состояниям будет собираться наш прототип. Так что сейчас мы можем сразу заложить как будет выглядеть hover, disabled и так далее. А при прототипировании агент уже поймёт что к чему. Сразу скажу, нам не нужно сейчас никакие прототипы в фильме создавать, нигде эту логику проставлять. Это нам совершенно не нужно. У нас будет сразу готовый прот-вариант. Но это только в последнем модуле. А что сейчас? Работает она
в двух режимах. Например, single, это если мы пишем component-variance-button, то есть указываем конкретный какой-то компонент или ссылку на него. И наш агент расширяет один конкретный компонент, создавая к нему вариации, которые по логике ему подходят.
И bulk, то есть пакетный, либо же всё сразу. Просто запускаем директиву component-variance без аргумента. Аргумент, если что это приставка к команде, как здесь вот, например, component-variance-button, тут же мы просто вызываем выполнение этой директивы.
Агент читает components MD, то есть даже не заходит в фигму, ему это совершенно не нужно. Сам находит компоненты с неполной матрицей и предлагает расширить каждый по очереди.
Single для точечной доработки, bulk или пакетный режим, когда дизайн-система большая и хочется одним заходом пройтись по всему.
Но мы знаем, чем это чревато.
Внутри обоих режимов одинаковые четыре фазы, а bulk просто повторяется на каждом компоненте.
Первая фаза это чтение. Агент читает дизайн-систему, компонент MD, для того, чтобы найти имя, но дойти текущую матрицу, какие есть вариации у этого компонента и, ну, в целом, понять его назначение.
После чего сам компонент он считывает в фигме, сравнивает, что-то там возможно изменилось, какие-то дополнительные сведения.
Второй этап это брифование. Он предлагает тебе, что добавлять, добавлять ли, с какими компонентами взаимодействовать.
Короче, дает тебе свое предположение о том, что нужно внести, и ты уже сам с ним общаешься, доуточняешь, что нужно сделать.
После чего он делает апдейт той дизайн-системы, которая у нас в среде.
И поскольку он уже простраивает то, как эти компоненты будут выглядеть, он знает, каких семантических токенов, возможно, не хватает.
Поэтому сразу в фигму их также добавляет.
И после этого последний, четвертый этап, как несложно догадаться, он уже просто создает эти вариации компонентов.
Итак, какие у нас вообще есть реалистичные ожидания относительно работы вот этой системы.
Стабильно у нас будут работать там три варианта, например, у каждого по четыре состояния.
Это уже 12 ячеек матрицы.
Это достаточно много, но с этим он будет справляться.
Если мы берем один конкретный компонент, за один прогон собирает их, как правило, даже без каких-то дополнительных правок.
Начинает он сбоить, когда у нас много разных компонентов, у них много разных состояний.
Например, пять и больше вариантов на пять и больше состояний – это уже 25 плюс ячеек.
25 плюс маленьких конкретных компонентов.
Соответственно, в таком случае инструмент начинает плыть, поэтому он сам тебе предложит раздробить это на итерации.
Это заложено в директиве.
Ну и что касается каких-то сложных анимаций, колечка загрузки, еще что-то, лучше это потом в прототипировании просто описать поведение этой штуки.
Здесь как-то вот это выстраивать, отрисовывать эти флоу смысла особо нет.
Но если там что-то очень сложное, то да, можно это сделать.
Но на этом этапе, учитывая, что прототипировать мы будем нормально, а не через фигму, смысла не вижу.
Итак, не стал запускать это под запись, просто чтобы не ждать.
Как обычно, я ему сказал, выполняй теперь это.
Просто вот так бесцеремонно закинул ему директиву, и он собрал список того, что у нас есть и насколько подробно оно описано.
Вот он тут перечисляет, что у нас есть в текущей матрице, сколько каждый компонент ячеек имеет.
Ну, ячеек это как формулировка, обозначающая вот эти конкретные варианты, отдельные фреймы.
И описывает полноту, насколько у нас достаточно подробно описаны вариации этого компонента.
Как видим, тут у нас есть с полнотой дырявый.
Он это сразу вычислил, и здесь дальше он уже предлагает, что конкретно нужно сделать.
Делит рекомендации по приоритету, критические, те, которые действительно стоит сделать, низкой, те, которые делать не обязательно, и скип, это вообще можно забить.
И сразу описывает, какие новые семантические токены нам понадобятся.
Surface Action Primary Hover, Surface Action Secondary Hover и так далее.
Ну, в общем, тут по сути-то все, что связано с хаверами.
До этого у нас их не было.
Я ему сказал, сделай все, кроме скип, и пошел процесс.
Вот он Foundation MD правит, добавляет новые семантические токены, собирает себе план, собирает все эти компоненты, добавляет их вариации и так далее.
В итоге выводит, какие компоненты он расширил, на сколько, что он добавил и так далее.
Также он проводит финальный аудит, обязательно сравнивает, что у нас везде проставлены стили текста.
Сравнивает, что у нас везде проставлены стили текста, везде поставлены переменные, никаким обводкам, просто цвет через код не задан.
И то же самое касается заливок, то есть ноль непривязанных обводок, ноль непривязанных текстов и так далее.
Вот, здесь он уже поступил более сурово, проставил везде вот эти вот токены и отступы между элементами, и горизонтальные, вертикальные, внутренние отступы.
Все это он проставил.
Также, обрати внимание, что он взял конкретные существующие компоненты и внутрь них добавил еще один параметр вариации и здесь же создал эти самые вариации.
Возьмем, например, Primary Action кнопку.
И что у нас здесь есть?
Во-первых, у нас три типа.
Ghost, Secondary и Primary.
И у каждого из этих типов набор их состояний.
Вот, например, Primary кнопка у нас может быть Hover потемнее, Disabled, Загрузка.
Сюда, вероятно, он предполагает, что мы добавим иконку, которая крутится.
И также Focus.
То есть, фокусировка.
Здесь у нас появляется обводка, насколько я понимаю.
Да, все, он полностью этот компонент собрал, собрал его вариации.
Соответственно, у нас здесь сколько?
У нас здесь целых 15 сразу так называемых ячеек.
Вручную это все делать несложно, но зачем тратить на это время?
Дальше.
Что у нас есть?
Inputы.
Также у нас было только два состояния.
Он еще добавил фокусировку и Disabled состояние.
По карточкам он предусмотрел здесь, что у нас может быть два типа карточек.
Те, которые срабатывают при Hover'е и те, которые у нас статичные.
Соответственно, добавил еще один параметр Property.
У нас появились Type Static и Interactive.
Static у нас при Hover'е не меняется, Interactive при Hover'е меняется.
Тоже хорошая штука.
Дальше.
Моделка у нас не изменилась.
Navbar Badge тоже нет.
Кнопка с иконкой у нас изменилась.
Появились дополнительные состояния.
Таблица осталась такой же.
Tooltip такой же.
В табах у нас до этого был только активный и неактивный.
Теперь у нас есть состояние при Hover'е.
Также для Dropdown'а с Select'ом у нас появились состояния, ошибка, Hover, Disabled.
Тоже все это дело у нас есть.
У Dropdown'а у этой иконки также появилось Hover' состояние.
И в пагинации тоже Hover' появился.
Все.
Так базово он расширил нашу компонентную базу.
Теперь мы можем продолжать сколько угодно.
Создавать новые компоненты, просить его выполнять то же самое и так далее.
И сразу скажу, если у тебя сейчас появится еще ряд компонентов.
Мы, ну разумеется, как я не раз уже отмечал, сообщаем ему.
Он добавляет это все в Components MD.
И в дальнейшем, когда мы говорим, давай-ка еще посмотрим,
каких у нас там вариаций не хватает и так далее.
Самому, чтобы даже не искать это.
Запускаем выполнение этой директивы.
Он видит сразу Components MD и видит сразу матрицу этих компонентов.
Какие уже есть у них вариации, у каких вариаций вообще нет.
И сразу предлагает добавлять вариации к конкретным.
Это очень удобно.
И еще раз напомню, если мы не хотим, чтобы он искал конкретно,
где что можно добавить, а хотим у определенного компонента добавить вариации,
просто снова вызываем эту директиву.
И еще в этом вызове добавляем, с каким конкретным компонентом нужно взаимодействовать.
Можешь либо из Components MD взять его название,
например, как здесь какой-нибудь бэдж,
либо прикрепить ссылку на этот элемент.
Еще раз, как это делается?
Просто выбираем этот элемент, Copy Link to Selection
и вставляем сразу после вызова директивы.
Какие у нас еще есть варианты?
Сейчас мы расширяли именно через состояние элементов Disabled, Hover и так далее.
Также у нас есть возможность расширять по размерам.
Это еще одна вариант ось.
Не отдельный механизм, а та же директива Component Variants,
та же фаза Brief, просто в MD добавляешь третье измерение матрицы.
Вводим мы эту информацию на этапе брифования.
Вот, например, у меня он подсветил только State.
Несмотря на то, что здесь в директиве указано еще работать с размером,
он оценил, насколько это вообще нужно и решил, что тут размеры другие и не нужны.
Поэтому предложил только State добавить.
Если ты считаешь, что какие-то размеры нужны дополнительные,
то ты можешь на этапе брифования, вот на этом этапе, сообщить ему,
что подожди, давай еще для кнопок добавим, давай для иконок добавим и так далее.
Чаще они нужны для отдельных таких атомарных элементов, таких как кнопки.
Чаще они нужны для каких-то атомарных элементов, таких как кнопки.
Реже для уже целых микроорганизмов, как, например, карточки.
И для каких-то совсем маленьких утилитарных элементов, как тултипы или бэджики.
Обычно одного размера достаточно, так же, как и одного состояния.
И давай подведем черту, когда лучше сделать руками,
когда лучше использовать этот метод,
а когда вообще нет смысла всем этим заниматься.
В принципе, здесь примеры расписаны, но если говорить кратко,
когда мы делаем через MCP, через эту директиву и так далее,
когда нужно сделать много, но эта работа достаточно банальная.
Если у нас у каких-нибудь кнопок нужно состояние предусмотреть или импутов,
с этим справится практически любой джун,
поэтому и агент с этим тоже справится прекрасно.
В целом и для более сложных задач он прекрасно подойдет,
когда у нас там много разных компонентов,
они могут быть даже сложными, проблем с этим никаких нет.
Руками нам лучше все это делать,
когда у нас добавляется какой-нибудь один всего лишь вариант,
когда у нас есть точечная оправка одной ячейки,
нет смысла напрягать для этого агента,
особенно учитывая, что у нас по количеству вызовов лимиты
для использования Figma MCP.
Соответственно, проще самому это сделать,
нежели, во-первых, тратить эти лимиты,
во-вторых, ждать, пока агент эту мелочь поправит.
Все равно моментально он это не сделает.
Ну и третий вариант, это когда нам нужны анимации прямо внутри Figma.
Смысла в этом никакого нет.
Здесь нагружать MCP, нагружать Клод для того, чтобы он там что-то отрисовывал.
Нет.
Вообще, в принципе, с прототипами внутри Figma он не может взаимодействовать,
их создавать он не может.
Но оно нам и не нужно.
Мы будем делать полноценный прототип сразу в веб-версии.
Итак, домашняя работа.
Прогоняем минимум три каких-нибудь компонента,
создаем для них дополнительные вариации,
либо по размеру, либо по состоянию.
Может быть, еще что-то придумаешь.
И для сдачи домашнего задания просто прикрепляем ссылку на Figma файл.
На этом все.
Удачи с выполнением домашнего задания.
Увидимся в следующем уроке.